so recently I challenged you guys to
email me with your best armored Core 6
builds and after looking over literally
a thousand submissions I think this one
was my favorite its name is microwaveen
and I love it it won the competition for
a few reasons first the decals are just
great second its design matches its
gameplay style which is to use four
pulse guns to absolutely cook most
enemies especially if they have pulse
armor but lastly and most importantly to
me the build has a quirk to it it
features a discovery that makes it
unique and in this case The Quirk is
that this build crams four energy
weapons onto the ve20b a generator that
has 150 points of energy firearm
specialization which typically does not
have the output to support four energy
weapons however this is one of the very
few setups that manages that feat
leaving only four en load to spare
that's an achievement in itself and the
build is really unique because of that
so this build is kind of the gold
standard for this video and I'm proud to
say that this video actually contains a
bunch of other builds that are just like
it aces that you can download and use
for yourself regardless the platform
you're on seven of these builds are my
own designs and they all have gimmicks
of their own as well for example ac1 is
one of the fastest viable builds that
you can pilot ac2 uses a trick to
achieve Infinite Flight and it never has
to touch the ground AC3 is designed to
reload exclusively in the weapons Bay
allowing for this unrelenting offense
AC4 deals almost all of its damage in
melee ac5 uses a technique that sets up
these guaranteed chainsaw strikes ac6
lets you focus on optimal energy weapon
management and ac7 has this play style
that allows for near instant staggers on
pretty much any enemy so let me showcase
all of these builds and more as I show
you what I discovered in the search for
the best build in armored Core 6. also
special thanks to displate for
sponsoring this video I have a New Mecca
themed print on sale now so check it out
in the link below
this first AC only uses parts that are
unlocked before chapter 2 and that's a
trend for all of the builds I designed I
wanted to make builds that are
accessible no matter what chapter of the
game you might be on so my second build
only uses Parts unlocked before chapter
3 then chapter 4 and so on and despite
using only chapter one Parts burnished
gold here is strong really strong I know
this because I stress tested it and I
was finally able to beat baltius here
without taking a single point of damage
and any build that can achieve that feat
is absolutely able to take on anything
else the game throws at you as well the
no hit run continues this build revolves
around a gameplay Quirk where arm
weapons can be reloaded and cooled down
while they're switched out in the
weapons Bay which is an OS upgrade that
you can purchase for two OS tuning chips
to get this to work well though we need
two weapons that have synergistic reload
and cooldown times and one of the best
combinations I've found are the gu1
pulse guns and the Haldeman shotguns
these weapons just have such a perfect
attack Loop together and by firing your
pulse guns right before they overheat
then switching to and firing the
Haldeman shotguns you're able to achieve
a consistent damage output that I simply
don't think is possible with any other
combination of chapter 1 Parts but the
other reason this AC is so strong is the
quick boost speeds it can achieve and
that comes down to two parts it comes
down to the knocked Royal legs and the
alula booster these two parts also have
just amazing Synergy together basically
even though they're not reverse jointed
the knocked Royal legs actually have a
really high jump distance stat giving a
significant distance boost to your
grounded Dodges and when these legs are
combined with the alula booster and its
short quick boost reload stat you
essentially have the perfect boost
interval where you're returning to the
ground at the exact moment your booster
is ready to Quick boost again allowing
you to constantly kick off from the
ground and benefit from your legs
amazing jump distance stat the fact that
I'm able to outrun the tracking of
baltius's machine gun fire on the ground
here kind of says it better than I can
really for this builds share code and
more information on the parts I use
click the link in the description
this next build is perfect for chapter
two and its gimmick is that it can
easily achieve Infinite Flight which
really hard counters the two bosses of
this chapter to achieve Infinite Flight
in ac6 all you really need is a coral
generator which are designed to be
drained completely to make use of their
exceptionally High Supply recovery stats
however these generators aren't
available in Chapter 2 so this build
uses a little trick instead that trick
is weapon recoil many weapons like
cannons or weapons with charge attacks
will pause you in the air while you fire
them so if you take care to fire those
weapons when you've drained your energy
Supply then you won't fall out of the
air and instead you'll stay suspended
while your energy returns this trick
even works on bipeds although in this
case we're using a quad because it just
has natural Synergy with those recoil
weapons in the air so this build is
called Eternal form and it has a bit of
an Autumn color scheme going on also our
arm weapons are the ronsetsu RF which is
actually named after a Japanese poet who
has a famous haiku about falling leaves
so it fits perfectly with our theme here
too but beyond me being a hardcore role
player with all of my builds we're
actually using the Run setsu RF for
another reason and that's because it's
great at mid-range and it has a Charged
triple burst attack that can be used to
keep you in the air as a backup if your
cannons are on cooldown and speaking of
cannons ours are the songbirds which are
pretty op on any build but they're
especially lethal on this one with their
double shot that keeps you in the air a
little bit longer than the other cannons
for this builds share code and an
explanation of the parts I use click the
link in the description
so this next build designed for chapter
3 is themed after the tester AC that you
downed in chapter one because I like to
think that even the most novice pilot
could get through the game with this
build you can kind of turn your brain
off with this one so it uses the same
gimmick as the first build I showcased
with weapons that reload and cool down
in the weapons Bay except where my gold
lightweight AC is fast and designed to
avoid hits this tester AC is heavy and
designed to take a lot of hits to make
up for our slow boost speed this build
uses another method to avoid attacks and
that's vertical jumps jumps are great
because they're uneven acceleration
often throws off enemy FCS and they
don't even consume energy so you can get
away with a lighter generator leaving
more load free for more defense instead
the way to play this build is to just
jump circles around your enemies while
focusing on the insane damage output of
the Zimmerman and Gatlin guns if you
want something else to do assault boost
in for a kick in between shotgun bursts
reverse joint legs are fantastic for
kicking after all I stumbled upon this
build during my first blind playthrough
and it easily overcame every challenge
that new game had for me for this builds
share code and more information on the
parts I use click the link in the
description
next up a chapter 4 build going into
this one I knew I needed to make
something that was capable of defeating
cell 240 consistently coincidentally I
also wanted to make a melee focused
build for this video and the Stars
really aligned here because it turns out
that this melee setup really comes
online in chapter 4 and this build can
easily overcome Ibis like 99 of the time
just look at the damage one combo can do
so let me explain this setup first you
charge your right shoulder drones with
R1 and release them these drones will
apply suppressive fire to your opponent
meaning they'll need to dodge these
attacks meaning it'll be less likely
that they'll Dodge your first melee
strike instead so your initiating attack
is actually the ve 67 lla laser Lance it
hits really reliably if you're aligned
horizontally with your opponent and it
deals incredible impact damage not only
that but this weapon unlike some other
melee weapons it has momentum that lands
you right next to your opponent which is
exactly where you want to be for your
follow-up attacks the trick with the
lens is that you want to charge up your
right arm laser shotgun while you're
stinging the enemy with your Lance this
way if your laser Lance isn't enough to
bring them into ACS overload your laser
shotgun will instead once they're
staggered though switch to the pile
bunker on your left shoulder and
position yourself for a Charged attack
for massive damage this melee build just
decimates any large boss as their
hitboxes and their longer than normal
stagger windows make them Prime targets
for the pile bunker and against cell 240
in particular for example all you have
to do is just wait for the right opening
strafe backwards diagonally and make
sure that you only Dodge her projectiles
after she fires them and before long
you'll spot this telegraphed attack
strafe left Dodge the projectile to the
left and follow up with the Lance and
the shotgun if you need to for the
guaranteed stagger by following this
approach you'll basically come out on
top against this boss every single time
meaning this build is perfect for S
ranking this Mission with these
so against bosses this is great but
against enemy ACS you'll actually want
to adopt a bit of a different play style
they have smaller stagger Windows
meaning it's difficult to land the pile
bunker unless they're in a corner or
unless you stun them with assault armor
so you should mainly just use the pile
Bunker's uncharged attack as a gap
closer instead and this can get even
better if you melee cancel it like this
and then you can just rely on your
charged laser shotgun punch as your
finisher instead against ACS you can
actually even consider purging your
right hand weapon entirely like a bee
losing its stinger this gives you the
ability to punch enemies which can
actually stun lock enemy ACS for three
consecutive hits while they're staggered
which does pretty incredible damage
thanks to your Basho arms and their
maxed out melee stat again links in the
description next build so what if I told
told you that Invincible rummy ranked
dead last in the arena actually has the
makings of one of the most powerful ACS
in the game all it needs is a few tweaks
to turn it into this what I call
terminal rummy a fast fragile variant of
mad stomp that is kind of designed with
one goal and that is to set up these
guaranteed charged chainsaw strikes on
your opponents and to tear them to
shreds in an instant the playstyle that
you adopt with this AC is kind of unique
because you actually don't want to
stagger enemies without thinking about
it instead you want to bring them to the
precipice of stagger and when they're
about to be staggered you switch weapons
then you charge your chainsaw and then
you stagger them and unleash the
chainsaw in that same instant and timed
properly this guarantees a direct hit
even against ACS which traditionally
have that quite small stagger window the
best weapon I've found to build up
initial stagger are the viento needle
guns that you unlock after chapter four
these things are just incredible they're
light with only five projectiles each
but they pack a hell of a punch and they
can be fired extremely quickly however
the main reason these guns work for this
build is because you know unlike
explosive weapons or shotguns these
viento guns allow for this fine control
over your opponent's stagger meter so
remember the whole point of this build
is to bring enemies to the edge of
stagger then switch to your other
weapons the chainsaw and the sweet 16.
once you've switched over you start
charging your chainsaw you get in close
and then you begin fishing for that
stagger with your sweet 16 shotgun I
really don't like just using the
Zimmerman for everything and the sweet
16 has its advantages too it's
lightweight which suits this build and
it's actually so short that you can fire
it Point Blank where some of the longer
shotguns actually clip through the enemy
but if the sweet 16 isn't enough to get
that stagger then you just keep charging
your chainsaw and then only switch your
right arm back to the viento and just
keep pushing for that stagger eventually
you'll get that hit off with the charged
chainsaw and this is a weapon that has
the highest direct damage adjustment in
the entire game it does so much damage
and I think it's my favorite weapon in
the game honestly so the toughest thing
about this build is keeping track of all
your weapons and sort of managing the
reload states of your viento guns and
also you have to make sure you don't
release the chainsaw too early because
that will lock you into place this is a
very fast but very fragile lightweight
build and that assists with your
positioning but it makes you pretty
squishy so I like to run terminal armor
for that temporary invincibility you
know this is terminal rummy after all
you are a fragile build you're all in on
that chainsaw combo and terminal armor
frees you up to pursue that goal without
worrying too much about your low Health
total and for S ranking many missions
this build is largely unparalleled it
ends fights so quickly with relatively
little ammo used as well and I easily s
ranked every Mission I attempted with
this build the links to this build and
reasoning behind all of the other parts
I chose again check the description
moving into New Game Plus let me show
you my favorite tank tread build so I
like the AC name albenoric for this one
as they've lost use of their legs and
their silver weapon slots are kind of
malleable on this build they're able to
be easily switched out to any other
laser and plasma weapons that you might
prefer
I say it's a new game plus build but
honestly only the headpiece is found in
New Game Plus and the rest of this build
can be mostly brought online after
chapter three when you can acquire the
nebula plasma rifles and the vp60 LCD
diffuse Laser cannon I love the
versatility of this Laser cannon because
it can be fired as a shotgun or it can
be fired as a Charged long-range Blast
for stagger instead and I love pairing
the nebula with this gun because it
provides reliable damage at any range
and staggered opponents can be sort of
forced to sit inside of the full
lingering AOE blasts that the nebula
provides but you might be wondering what
the gimmick is with this build well to
me the fun gameplay loop with energy
weapons is just learning when to charge
them because depending on the situation
charged or uncharged shots might be
better not to mention charging shots
also allows your web time to cool down
so there's a lot of skillful play that
comes as a result of managing overheat
as well and for the longest time I
didn't enjoy laser and plasma weapons
simply because I found it too difficult
to manage their overheat and their
charging modes and still manage to evade
enemy attacks as well however then I had
the idea of combining energy weapons
with tank treads and this is just the
perfect match because with the Fortaleza
legs you're able to sort of mindlessly
strafe and still be naturally avoidant
of attacks but that allows you the focus
you need to manage your energy weapons
instead and honestly I generally dislike
tank treads with any other weapon as I
kind of find their strafing gameplay a
little bit boring but that's what make
tank treads the perfect platform for
energy weapons in my opinion because
your mind is free to focus on weapon
management instead if you want to go for
heavier energy weapons then you can
simply consider the heavy tank treads as
well which is a pretty easy switch for
more information check the description
next up is perhaps the AC that I'm most
proud of on this list it's a build that
can stagger enemies in an instant
whether they're up close or at long
range but at the core of this build is
its melee weapon the plasma thrower this
thing is super underrated many people
use it on a biped and assume that it's
bad because it locks you in place while
you're swinging it and while it can be
used while moving on tank treads it's
not great with those legs either as tank
momentum often carries you out of range
for the second hit however where it
truly shines is on quads because while
hovering on quads you can still move
while throwing it and unlike with tank
treads quads give you fine control over
the direction you're moving in and as
long as you're hovering while you throw
it you are able to get this perfect
range for both plasma throws
both hits connect then most enemy ACS
will be staggered and the direct damage
potential it has is also absurd it also
pairs very well with the flamethrower
since you always want to be stuck to
enemies anyway and the status effect
from the flamethrower helps to open up
enemies to subsequent staggers creating
a loop where enemies get staggered in an
instant also the flamethrower doesn't
really need great FCS tracking as it
shoots out fire in a cone and our FCS is
actually the one that is optimized for
missiles because on our back are the
trueno missile launchers these are
unlike any other missile launcher they
fire two high-speed projectiles that
have a bit of tracking if you're locked
on and they deal a ton of stagger these
make up for the build's weakness at long
range but the special thing about these
missiles is that they actually Focus
really well At Close Range as well with
their High direct damage adjustment the
terrain know make for amazing stagger
punishers a fact that is even more true
when you consider that they can be fired
at staggered opponents before their
missile lock even completes because you
don't need missile guidance when firing
at a stationary Target so being able to
fire these early a lot of the time just
makes them deal way better DPS as for
the theme I've simply stolen Rock and
monson's amazing paint job from the
arena since he has that iconic plasma
thrower build but I also have a solar
themed variant of this build that uses
pulse weapons on the right side for its
close range damage and a shield on the
left side that you constantly hold up
for damage mitigation while you get
close this variant is also very strong
it's limited to close range but I wanted
to get a good Shield build up on this
list and I think this is one of the best
Shield builds that I could get to work
Link in the description by the way the
other Link in the description links to
this a piece of displayed artwork
inspired by armored Core and designed by
myself and Chan Lo this is on sale now
and if you purchase with the link in the
description before the 3rd of October
you'll get 29 off for this displate and
up to 40 off if you buy a number of my
other prints as well you guys have heard
it all before at this point but this
plates are special because their prints
are made of metal and they hang with
stick-on magnets that if applied
properly allow you to hang your prints
without damaging your walls which is a
great option if you're renting
especially a special thanks again to
Chan Lo for nailing what I had in mind
for this Commission Now back to the
video
so this marks the end of all of the
builds that I designed but of course
there are other builds that I want to
shout out as well first I'd like to
shout out the other winners of the
community competition as well as just
say thank you again to everyone who
submitted something I looked over every
single one and it was really hard
knowing that I wouldn't be able to
credit you all properly nonetheless in
fifth place we have the Toyota tereno AC
86 I love the initial D theme of this
build many of you will get that
reference there was a lot of time put
into the decals here and it shows the
weapons all work together here as well
and the build just looks aesthetic as
hell well done fourth place the
Kingfisher a blue yellow and white
design that plays on the kingfisher bird
with weapons that are all designed for
crit fishing basically they build up
stagger like I did with my other build
with the Vientos except this build is
able to capitalize on them at range with
the needle launcher or if you're at
close range you can use the pile bunker
depending on where you are I just love
how this theme was cleverly woven into
the gameplay and it all works together
so well serious props for that in third
place another car themed build this time
themed after the McLaren MP4 23 F1 car
with a astonishing level of decal detail
this build plays similarly to my worker
bee build except with the sweet 16
shotgun in the right arm and a diffuse
Laser cannon on the back amazing style
and great weapon choices as well in
second place we have blind Riot by kelva
skeleton which takes second place not
only due to its great theme and great
decals but because it taught me about a
unique gameplay Loop that I hadn't
considered before basically by sticking
enemies with the stun baton's charged
attack enemies are afflicted with a
delayed burst of electric energy that
goes off after a short countdown and
during this countdown you're supposed to
charge up your linear rifle and Unleash
Your attack at the exact moment that the
stun baton charge goes off delivering
what is a guaranteed Direct Hit to
opponents the charged melee weapon can
also be used to create a unique stagger
Loop which is an idea that I reckon
could inspire a lot of other builds as
well I will say that this build is not
like overpowered or anything but it's a
really fun anti-ac build and I just
think the gameplay Loop that you get
into with it is so cool and again first
place goes to microwave n by Stephen
Dunn who we shouted out at the start of
the video I love it but I'm still not
done because there are a few other
creators that I'd like to shout out as
well first up oroborough this guy makes
PVP builds that are true to the spirit
of this video as well with thoughtful
designs and unique gameplay twists to
every single one of them but unlike my
builds oro's builds are primarily
designed for PVP so I'd highly recommend
subscribing to his channel if PVP is
more your thing on that same note Mindy
is another great PVP channel to check
out as they upload a lot of extremely
unique PVP builds that attempt to break
the matter in some way usually and I
can't forget Kreit either crite puts out
the best guides that go in depth on
statistics in many of from software's
games and their breakdowns were an
invaluable resource to me when I was
putting together many of these builds
highly recommend their Channel if number
crunching is your thing Beyond these
channels there are too many others to
mention I'll link a bunch more in the
description but other than that thank
you for watching next up for me are lore
videos
until next time thanks guys
[Music]